[Musica]
sogni e certe volte sono incubi quelli
con la pubblica amministrazione speriamo
di raccontarvi sogni è un percorso
complicato come vedete ho tante cose
insieme abbiamo un quarto d'ora
quindi vi chiederei io cerco di essere
nei tempi e voi cercate di stare dietro
a questo ragionamento che non è un
ragionamento semplicissimo colore o
pubblica amministrazione
questo lo sapete dove siamo lo sapete
quello che ho fatto nella vita più o
meno volo andate a guardare sul sulla
biografia quindi stiamo anche questo e
vediamo da dove partiamo rapporti tra
pubblica amministrazione e cittadini
partiamo da un grado bassissimo questo è
il meno di un anno fa
il nostro livello di efficienza della
pubblica amministrazione di
competitività della pubblica
amministrazione grazie grazie grazie e
bulgaria grazie romania perché sono
sempre quelle non sempre le stesse
adesso ce l'abbiamo 33 dietro tutte le
classifiche ci abbiamo l'uno o l'altro
che ci salvano da essere proprio gli
ultimi però ci siamo ci avviciniamo
sempre di più anche perché loro stanno
correndo e noi molto spesso non corriamo
grazie anche a papà bergoglio perché
altrimenti la fiducia nelle istituzioni
sarebbe bassissima questa è la fiducia
negli italiani nelle istituzioni quindi
da dove partiamo partiamo nella totale
mancanza di fiducia e danno totale
mancanza di efficienza
eppure io sono trent'anni che almeno
costo di questa roba
una perversione sui trent'anni occuparsi
di pubblica amministrazione di passaggi
17 governi perché perché non ha
funzionato perché a furia di passaggi
successivi di mare e di riforme ci
ritroviamo a questo questi numeri che
abbiamo visto adesso cos'è che ci è
mancato dove sono stati punti allora io
credo che non esiste una strada maestra
non esiste un santo graal
ci hanno provato tutti giannini famoso
rapporto tutti i ministri che vedrete ma
sono veramente a me ricordano bellissimo
libro il novecento per chi non ha letto
tra voi ragazzi vi consiglio
assolutamente di leggere che l'uomo
senza qualità di musil
grande azione parallela è una cosa di
cui tutti parlano dei salotti ma non si
diventa ma in realtà è perché non
diventa ma in realtà perché ci hanno
provato in tanti in tra google e spesso
era sacconi
questo era cassese queste frattini
questo era bassanini cioè sera nicolais
questa è la brunetta questa era proprio
nei green fee questa questa è l'ultima
ministra che la madia non ci sono
riusciti perché non ci sono usciti
perché rimane alla fine tutte queste
marea di riforme ci hanno lasciato
detriti come se arrivassero
continuamente un date ondate successive
e siamo la mia moglie fiorentina dice
sono tutti raccattati della piena ecco i
raccattati dalla piena io non terminerà
da romano che non conoscevo perché ci
abbiamo tutte le cose raccattate dalla
piena alla fine non siamo riusciti ad
arrivare a un punto in cui la pubblica
amministrazione può essere veramente al
nostro servizio e noi ci possiamo fidare
io ho individuato quattro grandi nemici
4 idola mi ricordo ogni tanto di essere
laureato in filosofia e quindi ritornato
un abaco nei quattro grandi idoli d'ora
erano quelle quegli errori enormi che
fanno poi tutti che però se non andiamo
a cercare di scardinare non abbiamo
possibilità di cambiare davvero la prima
è la donazione delle leggi
i luoghi comuni e l'appello alla pancia
del paese qui stiamo guardate basta
guardarvi intorno a ogni e qualsiasi
cosa
adesso abbiamo proprio recentemente in
toscana una piccola classifica sulle
smart city subito attacca la pancia al
tu sei tu quello musei qui a siena ma
tutte le città italiane quindi attaccati
alla pancia l'allergia all'innovazione
alla cultura giuridica e immaginare
autonomia
partiamo dal primo idola tribus iniziali
sono troppi
quante volte abbiamo sentito dire
certamente un errore clamoroso
gli statali in italia sono circa 3
milioni poco più di 3 milioni in uk sono
5 milioni e mezzo in francia sono 5
milioni non sono sicuramente troppi
cosa hanno la reggina raineri
decongelati noi abbiamo una pubblica
amministrazione congelata in cui non può
entrare nessuno perché non si fanno
concorsi o pochissimi concorsi non può
uscire nessuno perché gli abbiamo
allungato i tempi della pressione della
pensione non possiamo premiarli perché è
proibito la legge dare premi effettivi
non possiamo punirli perché non possiamo
togliere a nessuno quello di diritti che
sono stati già acquisiti quale
organizzazione può funzionare senza
entrate senza uscite senza premi e senza
sanzioni
nessuna infatti non funziona
secondo è il lido lo specus la dea kalì
le norme non fanno le riforme ci siamo
talmente innamorati di cultura giuridica
che abbiamo riempito questo paese di
norme su tutto abbiamo scritto su tutto
la più eclatante forse sono la famosa
626 sulla sicurezza chi non ha sentito
parlare di un co è stato nelle
amministrazioni ha combattuto con questa
legge con i corsi sulla legge con i
pezzi di carta scritte sulla legge ma
possiamo parlare dell'anticorruzione
voglio parlare dell'anticorruzione piano
per l'anticorruzione responsabile
l'anticorruzione penn e prevenzione
nell'antico soluzione piano dei rischi
sull'anticorruzione ogni amministrazione
deve comporre nel qualche centinaia di
pagine per rispondere a degli
adempimenti
questo ha prodotto quello che io chiamo
necrofilia amministrativa cioè qual è il
sistema per rispondere a tutto sta fermi
e quella che io chiamo la burocrazia
difensiva quale come la medicina
difensiva che fa il medico nella
medicina difensiva si prescrive tutto
perché tu potresti averci dal gomito del
tennista al ginocchio della lavandaia
tutto potresti avere nella tua vita e
quindi io per non saper che fare se non
magari mi porto in giudizio ti faccio 5
a fare 50 mila esami che se ne frega
quanto costano se ti fanno bene ti fanno
male il burocrate difensivo fa rovescio
il broker difensivo per non essere
portato il giudizio non fa non firma non
firma perché di fronte a questa marea e
norme di leggi che abbiamo immaginato
fossero riforme semplicemente si trova
annichilito e quindi per paura non firma
quarto idola fori questa è la risposta è
dentro di te ma è sbagliata
guardate quello quello sì insomma è vero
che le tecnologie non sono non sono il
problema ma se abbiamo una classe
dirigente pubblica così ignorante come
quella che abbiamo adesso così tanto
ignorante verso le tecnologie è un
problema non sarà il problema alla
tecnologia ma se uno non capisce i
paradigmi nuovi cioè non riesce a capire
strategicamente perché le nuove
tecnologie possono cambiare il rapporto
tra cittadini istituzioni e imprese è
talmente ignorante che difficilmente
d'altra parte sono quelli che sono e noi
li abbiamo chiamati perché per fare
adempimenti giuridici li abbiamo
giudicati sulla base di quanto diritto
amministrativo sapevano è abbastanza
difficile che improvvisamente si trovino
essere innovatori ultimo ito la teate il
federalismo immaginario nel federalismo
immaginario lente è realtà dotato della
massima responsabilità della minima
autonomia pensare a un sindaco un
sindaco di un po di un paese è dotato
della massima responsabilità deve
rispondere ai cittadini ma di una minima
reale autonomia non abbiamo creato non
siamo stati creare capaci di creare
altro che monadi in qualche modo di
fortissima responsabilità e scarsa
autonomia e allora e allora forse è il
caso di cambiare paradigma perché costa
a cambiare paradigma
ma intanto la doppia far bene non ci
sono più soldi cioè che il vecchio
paradigma non funziona più perché
abbiamo tolto la benzina quindi non
funziona più così non poteva andare bene
perché non si può andare più avanti
perchè c'è crisi perché poi il mondo è
fuori dal palazzo dei comuni e perché se
non usciamo l'amministrazione non esce
non capisce perché il mondo è molto
complesso ma questa complessità che
l'amministrazione ha cominciato a capire
a vedere sempre come un pericolo invece
una grande enorme straordinaria
ricchezza due parole per ricostruire
scongelare e aprì le porte finestre e un
concetto di open government andiamo
veloci sullo scongelare lo scongelare
non può che voler dire aprire
saltiamo su questo non può che voler
sbloccare il turnover
diminuire gli enti e aumentare i giovani
una pubblica amministrazione
non c'è altro è io lo dico in tutte le
salse l'ho detto a tutti ormai questo
che la madia al diciassettesimo ministro
con cui combatto ed a tutti quanti
soprattutto quest'ultimo governo detto
fortemente non si può fare nuova
amministrazione
se non si mettono se non si immettono
nuove forze nuove giovani nuove
professionalità certo qual è il
contrapasso probabilmente avere un po di
enti in meno questa amministrazione è
diventata pletorica il gene egoista
diceva occhi come genetista e qui
abbiamo clienti egoisti ogni
amministrazione appena arriva ogni ente
appena arriva a nascere la prima cosa
che fa è cercare di sopravvivere
all'infinito
quindi si crea tutti i modi per essere
indispensabile quindi un po di enti in
meno e l'altra è chiaramente qui c'è la
famosa open government initiatives di
obama
chiaramente dobbiamo aprire
l'amministrazione fare un governo con la
rete perché l'amministrazione da sola
non ce la fa
governare con la rete vuol dire rendersi
conto che l'amministrazione da sola e
impossibilitata a raggiungere gli
obiettivi mandiamo un pochino più a
fondo e cerchiamo di capire quale a mio
parere il la pars construens per
parlarne in termini bach oniani cioè
quale quale cosa possiamo fare allora
adesso io noi abbiamo sviluppato un
progetto noi come forum fiamma non
stiamo portando un po in tutta italia
basato su quattro e sono quattro parole
inglesi ma in italia non venivano con la
stessa lettera per cui mi è toccato agli
slam inglese
la prima è questo è il modo per
ricostruire fiducia
immaginatevi una macchina immaginatevi
di dover fare un viaggio dal come quello
che ho fatto io oggi bellissimo da
firenze sono muro a siena dicevo ai miei
amici senesi che mi sono sentito così
contento di essere in toscana perché è
un passaggio talmente bello cosa devo
avere per avere una macchina devo avere
una macchina che funziona devo sapere
dove devo andare ad avere le ruote che
funzionano per una mappa ecco queste
sono quattro e la prima è
endorsement l'endorsement vuol dire che
la classe politica deve sapere dove sta
andando
non è possibile creare amministrazione
ha fiducia tra i cittadini e
l'amministrazione se noi non costruiamo
una classe dirigente politica in grado
di avere delle visioni quello di avere
delle visioni avere delle visioni vuol
dire sostanzialmente avere la mappa di
dove vuoi andare quindi nella nostra
metafora della macchina l'endorsement
tela ma ma altrettanto se tu non hai
engagement quindi non hai impegno dei
cittadini
hai una macchina che non a motore i
cittadini e l'impegno dei cittadini nel
cambiamento e nell'innovazione sono il
motore della macchina ma i cittadini non
si ingaggiano con call call nei talk
show né si ingaggiano attraverso gli
slogan i cittadini si ingaggiano
prendendoli sul serio prendere sul serio
i cittadini vuol dire chiedergli vuol
dire partecipare vuol dire creare luoghi
di partecipazione luoghi di ascolto di
una pubblica amministrazione che sappia
soprattutto avere le orecchie grandi
ascoltare più che parlare perché c'è una
ricchezza straordinaria dentro i nostri
dentro le nostre comunità che ha bisogno
solo di essere ascoltata perché ogni
volta che rimango verno a palazzo chigi
pensa di avere davanti un green field
tutto nuovo con la vendiamo lavagna
bianca non c'è niente devo ricominciare
tutto daccapo e nessuno che alza che si
alza la sedia diciamolo gentilmente che
si alza dalla sedia e va in giro a
guardare cosa c'è già nel mondo per
cercare di imparare dalle comunità
indigene dei cittadini e il motore ma
non basta neanche questo insieme ci
vuole ben powerman questa questo
cambiamento deve camminare su delle
ruote
le ruote sono una buona pubblica
amministrazione efficace e efficiente
che sia capace a fare cultura al proprio
interno e community
nella sua amministrazione perché se non
si lavora insieme quasi tutti gli
spiccioli oggi l'hanno riportato forte
questo tema se non si lavora insieme non
è possibile ottenere risultati e
un'amministrazione che non impara a
lavorare tutti insieme sia verticalmente
cominciando dall europa fino all'ultimo
quartiere sia orizzontalmente con i
comuni che sono
del circondario con amministrazioni
omologhe ognuno vede il solo il proprio
orticello sicuramente non si va avanti e
ultimo l'enforcement enforcement e il
sistema delle regole
non possiamo andare in macchina senza il
codice della strada perché non sapremmo
se dobbiamo tenere la sinistra dobbiamo
tenere la destra se il semaforo rosso
vuol dire fermarsi al semaforo posto
vuol dire andare avanti allora se noi
abbiamo endorsement quindi vera visione
politica engagement dei cittadini
empowerment dall'amministrazione è un
sistema d air force menti di regole
chiare probabilmente la riusciamo a
cambiare e questo è governare
io chiudo due minuti che mi mancano su
due grandi maestri di pensiero che anche
l'idv non sono secondo me
sufficientemente letti 1 ivan illich
attraverso questo il sapere tecnico
sapere delle amministrazioni diventa
sapere etico diventa etica cosa diceva
illich uno strumento conviviale è uno
strumento in cui che non viene dato a
un'elite di tecnocrati gran parte della
nostra vita siamo abituati affidarla
elite di tecnocrati macine prendiamo in
carico ce ne prendiamo carico
personalmente che faccio sempre questo
esempio la mia 500 era conviviale pure
io che sono una caparra in tecnologia
era un grado di aprirla guardare nel
cofano cosa c'era dentro le macchine ha
detto adesso non sono conviviali le apro
c'è scritto chi poi c'è una specie di
lastra d'alluminio che mi dice per
favore non la toccare se no perdi la
garanzia
ecco io vorrei che il governo e
l'amministrazione fossero delle vecchie
500 in cui hai prendo il cofano io
capisco che sta succedendo e che potessi
avere sempre il cacciavite della
democrazia per poterci lavorare dentro e
lavorando dentro trasformare il sapere
tecnico in etica sociale e perché questo
perché solo così l'amministrazione è in
grado di abilitare capabilities diceva
sen
che vuol dire abilitare capabilities
vuol dire dare a ognuno di voi a ognuno
di noi ognuno della comunità la capacità
di funzionare i funzionamenti diceva
un bellissimo libro di santuari
funzionamenti cosa vuol dire
funzionamenti vuol dire che
l'amministrazione non mi deve dire che
devo fare della mia vita
questi sono fatti miei che devo fare
della mia vita non mi deve dire cosa è
giusto e cosa è sbagliato dal punto di
vista etico ma mi deve mettere in
condizione di funzionare per raggiungere
i miei obiettivi attraverso il massimo
sviluppo delle mie capabilities delle
mie capacità azioni dice la brutta
traduzione in italiano del libro di
saint allora questo è vuol dire
trasformare le amministrazioni in
qualcosa di cui possiamo avere fiducia e
questo si può fare solamente attraverso
questo ivan illich attraverso il tema di
collaborazione di trasparenza e di
partecipazione
queste tre parole che benché sono poi il
nucleo del nuovo governo del dell'open
government che io sto sognando sto
cercando di realizzare attraverso tante
passaggi io nella pubblica
amministrazione perdo tantissime volte
per la pazienza tantissime volte la
pazienza ma non perdo quasi mai la
speranza con la speranza sto cercando di
realizzare
e proprio questo creare di cui un clima
in cui ci sia collaborazione trasparenza
e partecipazione
solo così l'amministrazione diventa
quella piattaforma abilitante in cui
ciascuno di noi può innestare in un
processo collettivo di intelligenza
collettiva e di comunità può innestare
la propria vita e quindi anche i propri
funzionamenti abbiamo visto l'importanza
delle relazioni in quel bellissimo video
le nostre relazioni vivono in un
contesto sociale e il contesto sociale
da alle amministrazioni pubbliche
un'enorme responsabilità questa enorme
responsabilità e anche la responsabilità
di ciascuno di noi non possiamo
attribuire a qualcun altro se no poi non
ci possiamo neanche lamentare
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]